احد معالمها مقهى العاليه اهلا بك احلام
مرحبا بكم جميعا بالفعل محظوظ كل من يزور
سيدي بوسعيد العاليه كما يقولون لها وتلقب
هنا في تونس احدى اشهر الوجهات السياحيه
عبر العالم افسح فورا المجال للصوره
لتتكلم والخبر اليقين في صباح العربيه
قهوه العاليه التاريخيه تفتح ابوابها من
جديد وانتهى الجدل الذي انتشر في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وفي مواقع خبر اعلام
التونسيه والدوليه ايضا احلى خبر في صباح
العربيه وجه حلو صباح العربيه على سيدي
بوسعيد وعلى القهوه العاليه هناك
وجهكم انتم ايضا حنونه دين وسهام وكل
الزملاء هناك على هذا الدرج زملائي
والساده المشاهدين التقط اشهر مشاهير
العالم السور الفوتوغرافيه التي طافت
العالم وتغنى الفنان الفرنسي الشهير
بجمال هذه المدينه وسحرها ومقاهيها
بالابيض والازرق اليوم تعود يعود فتح
مظلات قهوه العاليه التي اغلقت منذ ايام
وكذلك تعود كراسيها الى الساحه وينطلق
العمل فيها من جديد بعد ان احتدم الجدل
باعتبار وان للاسف هذه الحادثه وقعت خاصه
قبل شهر رمضان المعظم حيث تصبح سيدي
بوسعيد من اكثر المناطق التي يقصدها
التونسيون وكذلك السياح ويتمتعون فيها
بسحر القهوه العربيه
الساحره اذا اليوم ومن خلال برنامج صباح
العربيه ننهي هذا الجدل ونزف البشرى
القهوه العاليه تبقى دائما عاليه وبشرى
لكامل
لكي تتناولوا قهوه جيده مطالب صاحب مقهى
العالم انحلت
بالفعل في خلال الساعات الماضيه تمت
المفاوضات وتم التوفق والتوسل الى حل بناء
عليه تم اعاده العمل للمقهى وفتحت المظلات
من جديد وانتشرت الكراسي من جديد وعاده
البهجه الى المقهى الذي يعشقه زواره طب
احلام احلام شو السر دائما بنشوف اللون
الابيض والازرق وخصوصا في سيدي بوسعيد
وهيك بيذكرنا وسام سانتوريني باليونان
شفشاون في المغرب ليه هاللونين
[موسيقى]
اللون الازرق والابيض هما شارت ما يسمى
بالفرنسيه او ميثاق عمراني لابد ان يكون
ان يلتزم به اي شخص يقتن في هذه المدينه
او يفتح فيها اي عقار او يستغل فيها عقار
باعتبار وان هذه المدينه ذات الطابع
الاندلسي الضارب في القدم منذ قرون هي هي
تدخل في التراث الوطني والعالمي ايضا
وتونس متعهده بالالتزام بهذا القانون
وبالحفاظ على التراث وكذلك بلديه سيدي
بوسعيد وكل السلط فاللون الازرق والابيض
هما يعودان الى لون الارض ولون البحر لان
ارى سيدي بوسعيد هي مائله للبياض ولون
البحر هو لون ازرق سمائي جميل جدا
الاولنين الابيض والازرق ينعكسان من هنا
على البحر الجميل وهذا سر خصوصيه سيدي
بوسعيد التي تشبه بمدن اخرى في العالم لكن
تبقى ذات سحر حقيقه سحر خاص واحنا نقول
احلام المشاهدين انه سر تسميه مقهى
العاليه في سيدي بوسعيد انه المقهى يقع في
اعلى تل في سيدي بورسعيد سيدي بوسعيد
معروف مدينه تاريخيه وتستقطب السياح
الباحثين عن الهدوء والعزله والسحر
والجمال كيف يبدو الاقبال السياحه اليوم
على سيدي
الاقبال السياحه سيدي بوسعيد لا يتوقف
حقيقه في كل مواسم السنه باعتبار وانه
سيدي بوسعيد هي تجمع عديد الخصوصيات في
وكان الثقافيه التجاريه وكذلك الروحيه
والروحانيه
الباجي الذي يعشقه التونسيون وكذلك الزوار
من خارج الوطن اليوم ارقام السياحه
ايجابيه جدا في تونس وهناك تاكيدات حتى من
السلط الرسميه بان عدد الحجوزات هو في
تصاعد وهو يبشر بالعوده الى ارقام ما قبل
كورونا عدا ذلك فان سيدي بوسعيد دائما
عليها الاقبال هنا القهوه اللذيذه فطيره
البمبلوني اللذيذه والمشموم الفائح
الرائحه وكذلك المناطق الجميله والخلابه
جدا جدا جدا اتمنى ان تكونوا هنا في سيدي
بوسعيد في اقرب وقت
القهوه الشهيره
شكرا يا احلام
اكيد الشاي التونسي الشهير ههه شكرا يا
احلام شكرا لك
[موسيقى]